reviewing fashion isn't that hard anyone
can do it goodbye bye goodbye goodbye
welcome to another episode of girl in
sweatshirt reviews fashion my name is
Pierce helping if you did not know now
you know your life is different now
beautiful people wore beautiful things
while winning beautiful awards for
beautifully representing beautifully
real and fictitious characters in
entertainment the Emmys happened this
weekend people wore things let's review
the fashions of the Emmys red carpet
Kerri Russell this is beautifully
confusing it looks a little bit like
right before you got on the red carpet a
bunch of Mean Girls right and over to
you more like your dress is too pretty
ha ha and they ripped off the bottom of
it you also kind of look like a very
fashion-forward jellyfish but a
jellyfish that does not play by normal
fashion rules because that jellyfish is
wearing white after Labor Day
scandalous scandal fish bye goodbye
Claire Danes okay so a lot of people
were tweeting about Claire Danes looking
to gold or to tan and I say certains if
you want to cosplay as a tube of gold
glitter from Michael's craft store for
the Emmys you do you Grammy Malik Ramy
Malik Ramy Malik Rama Malik rammie
rammie Malak if you've never been here
before I don't pronounce things
correctly so you're welcome internet for
giving you what you want a reason to
correct someone I thought he looked
great
especially because men's clothing is
usually pretty boring and standard at
these award shows and he looks classy he
looks like the fanciest cater waiter in
all the town and I'll take two of
whatever you are serving because he's a
twin that doesn't help my chances with
either of them
Kerry Washington oh this looks so good
she's pregnant and she's glowing and
everything is good about this also dear
Kerry Washington's future kin
you're never gonna be as cool as your
mom and I hope that you just realize
that very soon in your life and become
okay with that cute Sofia vegara
looks exactly like Sofia Vergara always
seems to look on red carpets beautiful
sexy also I can't tell if my computer
just froze because all I see is that
hourglass figure goodbye goodbye Maisie
Williams from Game of Thrones
I thought she looks super cute this
looks different than a lot of the other
gowns that you see on the red carpet
it's fun it's young it's hip she's
wearing fake bangs on her forehead that
takes balls to wear fake bangs and I
also love that she's holding her clutch
the same way that I hold a baby which is
just like out and away from me and
making sure that everyone can see that
it's there so that someone takes it away
from me because I should never ever be
holding a baby cute kate mckinnon
I'm a huge Kate McKinnon fan and she
looks amazing and she wanted Emmy pick a
just the carpet match the dress it does
it does which is good because if you're
wearing a red dress on a red carpet it's
best if it matches says people that know
fashion better than me and just
literally repeating something that I
heard someone else say but it's cute
because now you just look like a
floating chestplate with arms and a head
Julia Louie Dreyfus ah you look amazing
your body looks sick in the super like
healthy fit way you're wearing this like
mushy oka dot gown and it's very cool
and interesting it's like sexy bedbugs
Priyanka Chopra this looks very swushi
and elegant I also like that it looks
like the designer just didn't know what
exactly they wanted to do at the top of
the dress they had like five different
ideas and at the end of the day they're
just like [ __ ] do it do them all do them
all up top one shoulder two shoulders
work over to one shoulder belt
underneath the boob just put it all on
angela bassett oh god damn it this looks
so good you look like you're dipped in
the finest must
i've ever seen and i love it taraji P
Henson oh this is very sexy and
beautiful and your face is so fierce
that I feel like offensive for
complimenting you or looking at you at
all like I feel like you're just gonna
tear me apart emotionally just rip me
down insecurity by insecurity without
saying a thing just by looking at me I
gotta move on because I'm feeling very
anxious
Viola Davis ah this is elegant and
beautiful okay Viola Davis here is the
tiniest violin playing just for me
because you look so pretty that I feel
sad about myself cute Laverne Cox stop
it stop it out stop it out what what
happened this Emmys did all of the
beautiful strong amazing actresses in
Hollywood just get on a group text and
we're like so we're all gonna look too
good for the Emmys right so that
everyone that looks at us just feels
like these human cauldrons of bubbling
over insecurities wink face emoticon
Kristen Bell this is beautiful and I
like that it's different it looks like
fancy wallpaper that you see in like a
fancy dentist's office waiting room
Sarah Paulsen ah
oh my god hey this is my favorite look
of the entire night this is just so good
it's just so good it's just so good and
it's just so good and it's just so good
Twix addendum to my thesis paper on you
looking good it's just so good no gotta
move on from that one Heidi Klum is
there I think okay I've been reviewing
red-carpet fashions for the last like
five or six years on the internet and I
had Klum just always there she's always
at every event looking stunning because
she's Heidi Klum maybe it's just
someone's placing the real doll of Heidi
Klum with different dresses on every red
carpet just for fun you're like that
game where's Flat Stanley
maybe it's like where's the Heidi Klum
realdoll sophie Turner also from Game of
Thrones this is a very like mature sexy
pretty look for Sophie and I really like
it she's got this cool braid thing
that's happening in the back it's like
I'm wearing a nightgown but it's also
like a sexy dress and I'm also kind of
like the sexy approachable member of the
coven maybe I'm in Captain Planet cute
Emily write a check off Xiao Jie go okay
Hana let me process this this is Wow ah
this reminds me of the moment in
Cinderella where the fairy godmother
twirled her wand around Cinderella and
changes her rags into a gown it's just
that like swirl moment this is like mid
swirl moment but it's like the sexy
version of Cinderella but good the black
almost unapproachable because she's too
pretty version good on you Emily Russia
how shout Tatiana maslany Sahni Milani
Milani a Keanu from orphan black that
also wanted Emmy that night I love this
look I think it's modern and simple and
clean and elegant and understated and
pretty I mean it looks like the panel's
over your petunia balls are just
floating there they look like red
townhouses just on your chesticles and
that's some prime real estate beautiful
Sarah Hyland oh I love what people take
risks on the red carpet and this is very
interesting to me it kind of looks like
she's a magician's assistant and she got
put in that box to be sawed in half and
then the magician opened the bottom half
of the box and her bottom half got
replaced with the legs from like the
volunteer from the audience
cute last but not least the kids from
stranger things they look fancy at
playful and also kind of too adult I
hope that you are still being children
because you are children and that makes
me nervous that you look like you're
becoming adults too soon you only get to
be kids once please tell me that you're
holding on to your youth and your
innocence where is your innocence did
you bring it where is it Millie is it in
that clutch did you bring your innocence
are you surrounded by good people are
you making
choices are they protecting you are they
keeping you safe are they making sure
that you get to have fun and enjoy this
for you and not for anyone else you
don't have to be an adult yet
don't be an adult yet you will be
stunted terrible things will happen in
your future developments oh my god
please stay young cute okay there are my
thoughts on the Emmys red-carpet
fashions let me know who your favorite
red carpet fashion Easter or Easter was
and I'm sure I didn't review plenty of
people that you probably wanted me to
talk about but there's only so much time
subscribe my youtube channel if you
enjoyed this at all also speaking of
time there's still time for you to
pre-order our new movie 3030 on iTunes
with myself Hannah Hart and mamrie Hart
it's a fun house party movie with tons
of other youtubers and comedians and
actors and actresses and it's just such
a great time so please pre-order on
iTunes now link is down below and that
is it I don't know
Tori Kelly Tori Kelly looks like old
Hollywood elegance but she also looks
like she's but she also looks like she's
smelling a fart I love Tori Kelly I
think she always looks beautiful at
every red carpet event but her face
always looks like she's just inhaling
some toots but damn that she looked
elegant sniffing damn toots